so my name is Kasia Brits and I'm a
population geneticist at 23andme my
background actually is in statistics and
math and I use that background to work
in problems in population genetics I
think it's fascinating that we can look
at genetic variation and learn about how
we evolved and how we got here and why
we are the way we are one of the
projects I'm working on is trying to
understand how different populations in
the u.s. are genetically similar in DIF
so I'm looking at african-americans and
Latinos and European Americans and
trying to understand their genetic
ancestry and I think it will help us
understand just the amount of genetic
variability that's in the u.s. as we
continue going forward I think it's just
phenomenal how much new potential
discoveries we can make how many
potential discoveries there are with the
genetic data as it comes out so you can
keep going and asking more complex
questions and more nuanced questions and
really dig into understanding how genes
and traits and ancestry all intertwine
and make us all human